still still three games up
so that's the good part
but a little too many draws for
for my liking
yeah i should have tried to get rook and
rook and knight against rook
but yeah in time i just
yeah didn't manage it yet
he was too solid i think i had
this against him before placing some
blitz games
this e6 line
what is it that you should do here
question mark
yeah i don't know why i'm asking mark
probably doesn't know
i want to get b4
yeah that's just moves you will get
banned
life for lifetime
okay let's try before
hmm
seems to be aiming for for e5 at some
point
maybe i should go bishop p2 normally i
would think bishop a3 though
it's a little more yeah
you don't get banned if you ask for a
ban
we don't we don't submit
to your your wishes your wishes that way
so if you if i ban the force in spammers
then it's okay
first of all was wrong was wrong with
having forsen's face in the chat
i don't see you could be wrong about
that
yeah of course i know about forrest and
i'm
i'm one of the biggest twitch streamers
out there
and so is he
we have a we have a club
i know i am i'm just feeding the trolls
but
i think that's part of the game isn't it
i don't know something about spam in
general just speaks to me
quite like spam
not speaking of the dish but
spamming the activity
so this is interesting i could go for
for an exchange sack here which looks
pretty promising
also rook c1 looks very nice
so many choices let's just sack the
exchange
this knight is so strong
and once his bishop is gone
then this diagonal is going to be huge
and his
queen could be in some trouble and there
you have the
the arrows going astray again
killer queen c5
yeah let's go queen c5
takes takes and i haven't decided
whether i want to
regain the exchange there then later
with 97 but it's certainly an option
regardless here it's pretty clear that
he's misplayed the opening and i'm just
much better now
mainly because of this knight
who would win the desire not to give in
exchange for the undeniable
allure of the bishop pair that's a good
question
it's a very good question and i don't
know the answer
bishop f3 maybe i misplayed this
maybe i misplayed this ever so slightly
i mean my position is still dominating
but i thought
it would be even better let's go bishop
three
could have gone [ __ ] b6 there as well
but yeah his problem was i go
with moves like rook d1 to d4 and
tonight is just paralyzing all of his
major pieces
and even though i don't win anything
immediately
i'm still still doing really really well
here rook d1
i feel like something tactical has got
to turn up here soon
knight d4 there's queen queen e7
okay let's just
make some air for the old king
okay i better play faster let's let's go
let's go for the attack it's always good
in time trouble
okay this should win 27 i'll take knight
of five
yeah this just wins knight f5 and
game over star mating threats
second b7 take back and his
pawn is not dangerous at all oh he's
trying to invite
rook c8 that's quite a clever trick
actually
okay now bishop three bishop e2
yeah and for those who just joined were
playing with uh
for their increment so